did you see labyrinth as a kid have you
rewatched it lately you might pick up on
some deep themes subtle references and
creepy overtones if you do almost every
adult will recognize the voice singing
the song over the opening credits of
labyrinth as that of pop culture icon
david bowie even before he appears in
character as the goblin king even today
bowie remains one of the most famous
performers in rock history although
unless they're music buffs younger kids
are unlikely to know much about him
while he may have been a highly
influential figure in music in the 20th
century kids without an interest in rock
and pop probably aren't all that aware
of his body of work of course labyrinth
serves as a fantastic introduction to
bowie as both actor and musician his
performance as the goblin king continues
to be one of his most beloved and it's
no wonder given that the character
exemplifies the rockstar glam bowie was
so familiar with
throughout his career bowie played with
persona and identity and although he was
clearly playing a specific role in
labyrinth he extended that tradition to
the film the end result is an infinitely
fascinating and instantly iconic villain
one whose true appeal only adults will
be able to fully grasp just fear me
love me do as i say and i will be your
slave
jennifer connolly landed the lead role
of sarah in labyrinth after an
exhaustive search that saw all sorts of
big names audition
in the end connolly beat out a bevy of
future stars including jane krakowski
yasmine bleath sarah jessica parker mary
stuart masterson lara dern and lily
taylor at the time connolly was only 14
years old and new to the entertainment
business but labyrinth wasn't her first
film she had already starred in three
other movies although none of them
cemented a legacy as strong as jim
henson's fantasy tale
of course adults will know that conley
went on to become a star and respected
actor one who eventually won an oscar
for best supporting actress for her work
in 2001's a beautiful mind today
connolly tends to take roles in mature
projects that kids aren't too likely to
watch so they may not realize just what
an impressive career sarah went on to
enjoy the funny thing is of course that
connolly looks remarkably similar today
to the way she did in 1986 making her a
highly recognizable star even for kids
that only know her from this 35 year old
film
there are some huge names behind the
scenes of labyrinth from george lucas to
jim henson but one that many youngsters
may not recognize is that of terry jones
who is credited with writing the film's
script terry jones was one of the
members of the groundbreaking comedy
troupe monty python and while the
group's name may ring a bell with some
kids they're unlikely to be able to put
any faces to the name jones who died in
2020 never had quite as high a public
profile as other monty python members
however he was pivotal in shaping their
unique brand of comedy and even directed
or co-directed many of their movies
including the iconic monty python and
the holy grail at the same time jones
became a noted children's book author
which is likely why henson wanted him to
tackle the screenplay for labyrinth the
irony however is that although jones is
the only writer credited with penning
the movie there were over 25 versions of
the script written between 1983 and
1985. many of them weren't by jones
either in fact it was a draft with
changes by famed screenwriter elaine may
that was used during production in the
end due to all the differences from his
original screenplay jones believed that
the finished product of labyrinth didn't
feel very much like his story
sarah is a pretty relatable character
for kids who know they've gotta grow up
but who aren't sure they want to take on
the responsibilities of adulthood
however grown-ups are more likely to
feel that her petulance and lack of
consideration for others are pretty
insufferable as is this little
catchphrase oh it's not fair
it's not fair it's not fair
you say that so often
i wonder what your basis for comparison
is
sure she has some heroic qualities
including intelligence grit and
determination but her immaturity makes
it hard to really like her especially
early on in the film it's possible that
if sarah was younger it would be easier
to forgive her youthful peevishness but
at 16 sarah seems a bit old to feel so
put upon after all this is a character
who gets mad at her baby brother for
taking her teddy bear and whose room is
full of toys and children's books it's
not that adults would necessarily find
sarah more likeable if she acted like a
grown-up but she might be less
frustrating if she actually took on the
responsibilities of being a teenager but
hey in a sense sarah learning to do so
is kind of what the whole movie is about
the mythology behind labyrinth is
clear-cut when someone wishes the
goblins will take someone else away they
happily grant their wish removing the
unwanted individual and making them a
goblin too but what's not as clear is
why jareth as the goblin king wants to
add to his already vast legion of
goblins while he may be their king
jareth seems to be human and perpetually
annoyed by the goblins he rules so why
would he want to turn toby into one
despite this jareth does everything in
his power to make sure he can keep baby
toby first by offering sarah everything
she wants in exchange for letting toby
go and then when she rejects his offer
by trying to thwart sarah's rescue
attempts
while kids probably won't question
jareth's motivations many adults will
recognize something doesn't quite add up
here
of course jareth may be bound to uphold
the tradition of turning unwanted people
into goblins to expand his kingdom but
since the movie never mentions this it
ultimately leaves you wondering just why
he needs another goblin in the first
place
kids could be forgiven for thinking that
the costumes and hair of the human
characters in labyrinth are in keeping
with the bizarre fantasy land in which
the story is set adults however will
recognize the film style as being
emblematic of an even stranger time the
1980s the 80s had a distinct look and
sound and the movie fully commits to it
consequently the costumes involve a lot
of vests flowy shirts puffy sleeves
sparkles and color while sarah's
costumes are relatively understated for
the time the goblin kings are
consistently over the top something
that's especially obvious in his hair
and makeup with an elaborate eye shadow
and gravity-defying hair bowie's look in
the film is both iconic and a perfect
encapsulation of the stylistic excess of
the decade the movie's 80s aesthetic
extends to its music too including the
score by trevor jones and the songs
which were written and performed by
bowie featuring a whole lot of electric
guitar and synthesizer the music may
seem dated to younger ears but bowie's
songs are undeniably ear worms
magic dance in particular is a silly yet
hugely memorable part of the movie one
that will have even modern day kids
dancing along
from the movie's opening moments sarah's
strong attachment to fairy tales and
fantasy is obvious
and while kids may miss it the play
sarah is rehearsing at the beginning of
the film is called the labyrinth this
would indicate that the plot of the
movie is sarah's fantasy come to life
and formed by the play she spent her
time memorizing yet the film slips so
seamlessly from the real world of
babysitting and responsibilities to that
of goblins and mazes that the land of
labyrinth comes across more like a real
place than a fantasy of course that may
be by design for someone who's as
imaginative as sarah the line between
fantasy and reality might not be all
that strong nonetheless the lack of
clarity leaves a lot for adults to
interpret that kids are likely to
overlook including how each of the
characters exemplify sarah's various
fears and desires and how the story
itself is a metaphor for learning to
accept your more adult responsibilities
at one point as sarah makes her way
through the labyrinth she falls down a
hole the scene is reminiscent of alice
falling down the rabbit hole at the
beginning of alice in wonderland but in
this case the hole is lined with living
stony hands that catch sarah before she
hits the bottom the hundreds of hands
lining the hole and their penchant for
coming together to form faces and talk
is undeniably compelling in fact the
sequence is generally a remarkable feat
of creativity one of the many moments
that make labyrinths so captivating for
both kids and adults at the same time
though it's hard not to look at all
those hands gripping the teenage sarah
and think about the matter of consent
given that those hands appear to be
conscious and not particularly worried
about where they're grabbing her adults
may find the sequence a little more
disturbing than kids
there's a lot to love about labyrinth
but the relationship between the goblin
king and sarah shades into unsettling at
times essayist alison stein noted in the
atlantic that from the movie's outset
jareth clearly doesn't just want toby as
she wrote he wants sarah he wants her to
love him and his longing increases
becoming more and more creepily clear as
the movie progresses there's both a
paternal appeal and stranger danger in
jareth as an adult this is more than a
little disconcerting and no sequence in
the movie is more troublesome than the
scene in which sarah imagines attending
a masquerade ball
over a song about falling in love the
masked goblin king makes a beeline for
sarah and as they dance the charge
between them doesn't feel at all
appropriate of course for kids and even
teenagers the goblin king's menacing
magnetism may make him compelling even
attractive adults though will be more
likely to recognize the disturbing
undertones this evokes and see jareth
for the genuinely creepy villain that he
is
when sarah finally makes it to the
goblin king's castle she finds herself
trying to get to both toby and jareth in
a room right out of relativity one of mc
escher's most famous works the black and
white lithograph depicts a room full of
staircases but only some seem to obey
gravity while others go up or to the
side meanwhile the people walking along
the staircases and standing on the
landings all seemed to conform to
different gravitational pulls the idea
escher so vividly brought to life in his
art is envisioned in live action in the
scene in labyrinth this is something
adults and possibly even some kids will
notice instantly although younger
children who aren't familiar with the
art world won't understand the reference
still there are clues in the movie that
this is a deliberate homage not only
does a print of relativity hang on the
wall of sarah's room the closing credits
of the film include a special entry
thanking the estate of m.c escher sarah
may not be the easiest character to like
but she learned some valuable lessons
during her adventures in the labyrinth
these are lessons that kids may
appreciate too even if they won't be
nearly as aware of them as adults will
much of what sarah learns centers on the
realities of life when an adult isn't
there to save you for example sarah
frequently complains that what she
experiences isn't fair but when hoggle
makes a similar complaint sarah realizes
that he's right sometimes life isn't
fair and that's just the way it is it's
not fair no it isn't
but that's the way it is
after that she stops complaining about
fairness and faces the challenges of the
labyrinth head-on fair or not by the end
of the film sarah is able to recognize
that even though her journey has left
her more mature and capable she still
needs the friends she made along the way
who are able to bring enjoyment and
whimsy into her life it's a smart but
subtle lesson about the need to balance
the responsibilities of adulthood with
freewheeling fun every now and then
something even the most serious adult
needs to remember
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]